am anfang war die angst und hier kommen
in einem rhythmus klatschen
wir können
ich habe eine frage das thema aufwärmen
macht das nicht mehr sind in beheizten
räumen nein sogar verkehr völlig
verkehrte an die regeln müssen wir uns
halten und 30 euro aus das ist klar also
dass wir letztlich nur eine
spaßveranstaltung eine wasserflasche
fast immer zu hause mit wunderbaren die
flasche aufwand
wir haben gesehen die reaktion tendiert
gegen null wie wunderbar
also da setzen wir bei dir nach
steigerungspotenzial du muss kapieren
das ist nicht so einfach für dich wenn
du leader zu sein hass und wann voller
und jetzt bist du verloren jetzt bis
jetzt stehen
er hat ja
ich denke jetzt gegen körperlich nun
immerhin auf kreisliga niveau sollten
sie nun beginnen die tage der isolation
[Musik]
monika
frau professor dr
wir haben uns freiwillig in isolation
begeben um der gesellschaft zu helfen
und was wir damit fragen wollen ist sind
wir helden
wir sind dann mit meiner persönlichen
helden erweisen sich schon so dass wir
alle irgendwie maßnahmen einhalten
können selber bundes die angeordnet
werden und
unsere kontakte zu reduzieren wie viel
krasser ist denn so die neue variante
jetzt also wenn delta der erste fc köln
wäre welcher verein wäre dann omikron
spielt schon mit champions league ist
keine frage ob die jetzt final material
ist dass wir jetzt durch so genau
vielleicht dortmund bayern für witwen
und waisen werden wahrscheinlich
gefährlicher die serie endlich zwei
junge gesunde
also es gibt keine chance dass ich die
wohnung bald für mich auf
und ist ein schlechter
mit schockiert und wird ab 24 stunden
schon so bei
meinen tod denkt hey so meine ich das
gar nicht
hey fabian wie finster ist mein bild
hallo fabian und ich wir sind ja jetzt
seit ewigkeiten schon in dieser
quarantäne vigier deswegen die frage was
macht mann bei einem streit auf einer
weltraumstation man kann nicht einfach
vor die tür gehen wir sagen können wir
ja machen ich habe den gummibärchen
dabei wenn der unfall entsetzen und
berührend verrichten stunde gummibärchen
frischen luft schweben das wird sich
jetzt was halten sie persönlich
eigentlich für gefährlicher aliens oder
querdenker wie querdenker sind momentan
sehr viel unmittelbarer jährige jetzt
die instandhalter wegstrecke vor sich
hin ich habe auch noch von keinem alien
gehört das mit einer fackel in der hand
ein spaziergang in sachsen gemacht hat
sage ich mal ne weile gibt es schon
erste gespräche
haben sie es schon mal gesehen oder
irgendwas in der art ja ich glaube und
nicht drüber reden das ist
[Musik]
schlechte schon
gibt es noch so ein weltraum gruß zum
abschluss so was wie waidmannsheil nur
in astronauten sprache deutsch
dann wünschen wir uns alle eine weiche
landung in 2022
[Musik]
jede zeit hat die helden die sie
verdient naja immerhin haben wir die
schöne aussicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super trägt wir haben es euch
sie auch echt clique aus heute